preparing for emergencies today clark
county fire and las vegas fire practice
high angle rescue techniques
they did this at the high roller at the
link these types of exercises really
important to firefighters
who of course have to respond to several
high-rise emergencies each and every
year
we're here to collectively train and
work with a high roller
and also in coordination with the city
of las vegas fire department
to train on this very complex problem it
could be
you know victims trapped up in one of
the pods if if there was ever a
mechanical failure of
of the high roller our technical rescue
technicians
who are also firefighters you know they
have a lot of different skills to train
on
and this particular skill which is high
angle rescue
is very unique because of its height off
the ground the high roller offers unique
opportunities
for our partners at clark county and the
city
to train in unique scenarios that may
not be your typical rescue situation
come out once a year work with caesar
entertainment as well as clark county
fire
to get our training in get our people
across and get some experience
if this ever was to really happen as
part of the technical rescue team for
the city and the county we do a lot of
training of high angle low angle rope
rescue
we're simulating that the wheel the high
roller wheel
gets stuck and we have people inside we
travel up to the middle of the
high roller and we're able to send
people across on the cables
get into each pot individually set up a
system
from the pod to lower everybody down to
the ground having these training
measures on a regular basis
ensures that all of our guests that
board the high roller
are safe 100 of the time